there are men one day son you'll be in  love immeasurable they were women  I'm Michael I work in the restaurant  there are you hungry there is hope I've  met someone  what do you do when you're not eating  there is darkness  incubation fairly aggressive they kind  of smell anymore you can't smell it for  they don't even have time to give the  disease a name there's over 100 reported  cases in England France Italy being  smell all gone that's the disease and  then the loss of another sense you just  I think it's okay to panic now  what should we do  still pleasures normal death  that's how the darkness descends upon  the world  come back to me  the shining moments to offer one  acceptance  I said love there is nothing  you